the shocking end of fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald has left many fans
scratching their heads as to what it
really means and how it ties in with the
Harry Potter movies yippie ki may be
lovers it's Jan here and in this video
I'm breaking down all the details in the
twist ending to fantastic piece too and
explaining why you can't trust
Grindelwald
keep watching to the end to find out
what crucial timeline details have been
retconned in the sequel and to celebrate
the release of a new Fantastic beast
movie I'm giving away an amazing set of
official movie merchandise including a
very cool set of nifflas tap the gleam
link in the video description to enter
the giveaway spoilers ahead of course so
take care if you haven't seen the movie
yet in fantastic beasts to credence goes
on a quest to discover his true identity
and after chasing down a red herring
that his littlest Rangers brother Corvis
in the final scene Grindelwald tells the
young wizard that his true identity is
alrea stumbled or to support this
revelation Grindelwald takes the baby
chick that credence has been taking care
of and it transforms into a phoenix
potter fans will know that Phoenix's are
associated with a Dumbledore family and
forks was a Phoenix who was a companion
and protector to Albus Dumbledore at
Hogwarts this reveal about credence has
shocked Potter fans as until now the
character or alias Dumbledore has never
appeared organ mentioned in any movies
or books which is strange given
Grindelwald predicts that he and/or
alias will together go down in history
as they remake this world during the
reveal Grindelwald also tells credence
that his brother seeks to destroy him
implying that Dumbledore plans to kill
credence this patently isn't true as
during the movie it was Albus who asked
Newt to go to Paris and try to save
credence in fact JK Rowling herself says
in an official featurette release for
the film that whatever you think you
know at the end of the movie might not
be the case so let's go through all the
evidence as to why Grindelwald could
very well be lying which is made in the
movie about what a master of persuasion
and deception Grindelwald really is
right at the very beginning President P
curry remarks that they had to cut out
the nefarious Wizards tongue and change
his guard three times because he's so
persuasive little did she know that
Grindelwald had actually recruited
Abernathy to his cause and switched
places with him and
Natha ends up rewarded with a forked
tongue of his own in Paris Grindelwald
recruits the bounty hunter Grimson who's
supposed to be hunting down credence he
also recruits a huge number of wizards
to his cause in the speech he gives at
the end and he even tricks the
sweet-natured Queenie over to his side
which I'll talk more about later in fact
it feels like Grindelwald is more than
just persuasive he's actually the man
behind the curtain pulling on everyone's
strings and bamboozle everyone with red
herrings and tricks all for his own
nefarious ends for example when
Creedence goes to find the nanny who
looked after him the Bounty Hunter
Grimson kills her on Grindelwald orders
it seems like Grindelwald wanted rid of
her to clear up any loose ends and true
answers she might provide to Creedence
Grindelwald also had the Lestrange
family history moved from the French
Ministry archives to the Lestrange
morsel ium which raises questions as to
why he did that and what information he
might have manipulated after that scene
mute points out to tina that all these
things including queenie the family tree
it's all been bait to get them to the
rally that Grindelwald is holding and
you can see during Grindelwald speech to
the Wizarding community that he's very
skilled in rhetoric and manages to
convince many people he knows how to
make his extreme positions and view
sound almost reasonable and sensible to
them director David Yates has said that
Grindelwald is quite different to the
other big bad we all know from the Harry
Potter series bolder more Yates said if
you disagreed with Walder more he would
kill you in an instant but Grindelwald
is incredibly beguiling he would rather
win people over to his side's than
annihilate them and he's smart enough to
understand you have to win hearts and
minds not coerce people to gain their
allegiance which is why I think we can't
take what he's saying to credence about
his identity at face value
he knows that Creedence is desperate to
discover his real identity and so he
preys on that to set Creedence against
Dumbledore he even conjures up a Phoenix
to bamboozle him into believing the line
so why does Grindelwald need to use
credence against Dumbledore while in
fantastic beasts - it's shown that
Dumbledore and Grindelwald were lovers
when they were younger and they made a
Blood Pact where they promised they
would never fight each other the pendant
that Grindelwald was and which Newt
sniffler steals from him contains drops
of blood from the two wizards and the
actual existence of the pendant seems to
physically prevent Dumbledore and
Grindelwald from attacking each other
directly at the end of the movie newts
gives the pendant to Dumbledore who
indicates he will look into whether he
can destroy it part of me wonders if
Dumbledore seems a little reluctant to
break the Blood Pact and whether he's
holding out hope he can turn his old
friend away from the dark path he's
chosen the other major reason that
Grindelwald needs credence is because of
his immense power as an obscure eon
normally an obscurus would have killed
its host by the age of ten but credence
has survived into adulthood
demonstrating his superior Wizarding
powers and in fantastic beasts - by the
end of the movie we finally see that
Creedence has gained control over his
power Grindelwald gives him a wand and
Creedence uses it to blast away the side
of a huge mountain in the distance this
is in stark contrast to the first movie
where Creedence explicitly said he
didn't want to control his power you can
control him please I think I want to
mister now that Grindelwald has
maneuvered credence to his side and he's
been able to focus the young Wizards
rage he will presumably use him as a
weapon against Dumbledore next credence
is perhaps one of only a few Wizards
powerful and foolhardy enough to
confront Dumbledore as remember how
earlier in the movie when Grindelwald
asked his followers if they would go to
Hogwarts an attack Dumbledore not one of
them said they would what's interesting
about credenzas identity is that it's
changed in every film so far meaning it
wouldn't surprise me if we discover
credence his true family line in the
next fantastic beast movie he might be
connected to an alternate character from
Patil or after all we see he's good
friends with Nagini
who will end up eventually as Mulder
more snake so could there be a
connection between credence and Valda
more let me know what you think another
victim of Grindelwald manipulations in
fantastic beast
2 is queenie who ends up becoming a
follower of the dark wizard although I
felt her turn to the dark side was a
little abrupt you can see why she
personally feels attracted to the idea
of overturning the restrictive laws
which forbid her from having an open
relationship with muggle Jacob I do
wonder whether any foul play was at work
though after all there was
teapot which kept trying to serve her
more tea so I wondered whether anything
was slipped into her drink to make her
more susceptible to Grindelwald guile
the thing quite a bit of discussion in
the fandom that the timeline for
credence being Albus Dumbledore's
brother is also problematic the main
issue people have identified is that
when the first fantastic beast movie
came out in 2016 Ezra Miller said in an
interview that Creedence was 18 years
old in that film fantastic beasts and
where to find them was set in 1926 which
would have made his birthday sometime in
1908 or 1907 and that just doesn't fit
very well with the fact that the books
established at Albus Dumbledore's mother
Kendra died in 1899 many years before
Creedence is suppose at birth date
however some new evidence just came out
via the original screenplay for the
crimes of Grindelwald which indicates
that the shipwreck scene happens in 1901
in that scene littlest rains what
credence with her brother Corvis just
before the ship sunk meaning credence
was a baby in 1901 and therefore his
birth date so a couple of years earlier
would fit roughly with the year 1899
that Kendra Dumbledore died now that
still doesn't mean that credence is
definitely a Dumbledore it's just that
some retconning seems to have happened
for fantastic beasts to to make credence
his age line up with the Dumbledore
reveal so do you think Grindelwald is
lying to credence at the end of
fantastic beasts - and if you do who do
you think credence really is I've added
a poll where you can vote just tap in
the top right of this video and after
you've cast your vote you'll be able to
see the results let me know what you
think in the comments below and remember
to click on the gleam link in the video
description for a chance to win a cool
fantastic besmirch pact tap left for
another theory and ending explained
video or tap right for another video
you're sure to LIKE and if you enjoyed
this remember to subscribe and leave a
thumbs up for more videos like this
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers